all right so we've got three here on the
board can we start to talk through them
they'll be right let's have a look at
the very first one here now we've got a
couple of lines of working I'm going to
make some minor adjustments you see
there's an equal sign here which is a
common thing I've seen this all
throughout in fact you can see it a
couple times on this board I'm going to
very delicately arrays this equals sign
can someone tell me why someone told me
I yeah thank you go ahead very good okay
so we we are thinking okay next step
next step I actually thought about this
for years I'm like why especially from
like you're setting you're right people
do this a lot we're like equals just
going along even though these are
clearly not equal things I kind of
wonder if it's because of and see them
on your tables but I think they're
training us when you're calculator right
press equals to indicate do the next
thing like go take action and then move
forward right which is kind of I think
what you're trying to do you're like oh
I had this thing the next thing I'm
gonna do is start this process right
right but they are as Zack you said very
emphatically not the same thing unless
you have a to the X which we do not we
now have a derivative over here I think
actually a bit of simplification has
already happened this is like close to
the end so can someone tell me what's
the actual rule we used with question
one what are we differentiating with
we're using the quotient rule
very good so you've got your I'm still
I'm still hyper suspicious of myself so
I still years and years later I still
write down U and V so that even if I
don't go ahead and do this here it's one
less thing for my brain to have to do to
work out which one is which and then off
I go okay
said again
this is such a common like I didn't make
this out I like this from my your on the
van teacher actually so this is how you
know and I'm sure they learns it from
their earlier kinda I guess alright so
um can I get some hands-on agreement
with this final answer yes quite a few
hands up right that's because you know
alright thanks his own just um you
thought this was back to France huh
how many people had it the other way
around no I saw a few okay now if I
start to think about what this vu - is
going to start looking right right V you
- I'm gonna get X - 1 x once it's gonna
give me 6x right that's you - in this
case in fact it might even help you if
you haven't already you can see I'm sort
of skipping ahead but Shamu is actually
laid this all out so that we can see
what the V and U and the V - and you -
are if you're in doubt like this helps
you work out what is one right so this
is going to be what do we say 6x this is
going to be one I'm actually
increasingly seeing when you do this -
you V - on the end there
right you can have minus 3x squared I
think this is okay yeah who's gonna pay
now okay
that's rights right just one last thing
before we leave off this there are two
lines of working here and I'm interested
why there are two at this point here the
differentiation is done it's finished
okay so I didn't ask you to factorize
but it's a really good idea to factorize
why is that generally why do we why do
we go to this next step so frequently
even when asked not to do it why is it
easiest right is this simpler it looks
nicer boy what are you okay so if there
were if we factorized and then you're
like oh I've got a common factor I could
cancel further that's that's a plus
right I'll give you another one
we often not in this case because I just
wanted this to be a start but we often
go from a first derivative to what what
often the next step okay interesting I
mean we do go to a secondary first area
but we use the first derivative itself
for something useful Eddie what do we
see
to find stationary points right now I
hope you can see it's easier to find
stationary points off of this than it is
off of this okay you're like okay I'm
gonna get a stationary point when x
equals zero and when x equals two then
I'm done you can do that cuz factorized
right I'm actually gonna argue if you
want to do differentiate again and get a
second derivative this is not the form
you would use it in you'd actually use
this one but guess what I wouldn't
differentiate again unless I was forced
to anyway why not have a look
yeah but why she's like why can't I be
bothered okay because this thing's gross
I will avoid it as much as possible
differentiating again because it's just
gonna become even more garbage mess that
already is okay all right next one long
we use questionable first this is this
is chain rule fantastic so again I'm
going to delicately actually instead of
deleting that I'll just fix it this is -
I know I should've said this before but
this is why there's no F in this first
question right same with this third one
so if you started talking about f of X
and all that like pay close attention in
fact this lesson more than recent ones
it's really going to matter what you
call this derivative you'll see why in a
second alright so let's just have a
quick look powers come out the front in
X is reduced what's this 8x represent
it's the it's the inside derivative very
good because you differentiate this plus
3 is gone and then you're pretty much
done no need to expand or anything like
that and then lastly we've got product
rule shown Bob's gone all the way and
this is very very simp